what is happening there reject nation
greg and john no coy
with us
today we were shooting this after
obi-wan
about two in the morning yeah funny
story about koi
so like a couple weeks ago he's like all
right so i have a trip i gotta go on but
i booked a flight and i should be able
to come back here you know like i should
be landing around 11 p.m so i'll be able
to make it in time for miss marvel cool
talked to coy earlier i was messaging
him he's like sorry phone died i'm at
the black phone premiere and at the
after party i'm like oh so you got back
earlier to go to this you sure you can
still come yeah i can be there don't
worry i will 1 30. ah guys i'm tired i
don't think i can make it i don't know
my body's giving up
because i was like if you can't make it
i totally cause i felt bad about the
thought of him like flying in to come
here
and then like wait a minute so you got
here early and then you just went to a
party that's right man got a schmooze
energy to go to a party but not join us
here i got your homies movie all righty
well here we are
and uh it's gonna be better without him
you guys watch we're gonna kill it uh
leave a like
leave a like for koi also subscribe
click the notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next
miss marvel episode is up which we'll
have coy in it hey full length watch
along as we sync up with the time code
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page cover a whole
bunch of shows over there as well full
length watch long's reaction highlights
for certain shows exclusive and thank
you to the prepper people for helping us
edit these really crazy hours of our
lives anywho let's get to it
and say and tweet koi tweek koi this
section of the video it'll make them
feel good it'll make me laugh
oh
snap
[Music]
foreign i found it
i found the bangle looks cree like
yeah that blue hand
should we be concerned it's on a severed
arm
you heard what that man from the temple
said
he said we would need to
[Music]
mama's got a past i told you the british
have probably looted this place twice
over by now
then one will have to do
oh ho there is even a chance this bang
can take us back home we have to try
oh snap
[Music]
did you see that
no
you go that way
as for your great-grandmother aisha that
was the last time we saw her
it kind of looked like the ten rings
logo beneath them in the temple there
aisha was from another dimension
and
so are we wow
golly you
all
looked
very good for being around in the 40s
thank you
okay
not all of us
kid's 17
that's relief
[Laughter]
back on the table she is adorable
i i i never said that
no that i don't think that i just i i'm
trying to this is so awkward for you
guys
the least we can do is protect aisha's
family we didn't even know she had any
until you put on that bangle and we
sense the presence of noor nor
that means light right you're a girl no
that's not it there's no within us as
well
but we can't access its full potential
in this dimension but maybe because
you're from here you can
the bridge
it was aisha's wish
to bring us all home
and now you must finish what you started
so where exactly
is your home
and also what are you like
respectfully
[Laughter]
so many questions we've been called
unseen the list goes on
but what we're most commonly known as is
jin
oh god i'm sorry did you just say jen
[Laughter]
also they need my help which means i
need your help i guess why not i just i
don't really know
how i can help a group of
ghosts
and their average looking sun
you're good at math do you know anything
about interdimensional travel off the
top of your head of course specifically
that of the nord dimension
that's n-o-o actually no that reminds me
of a paper i read
uh i think it's by dr excellent
thor connections
you're trending
oh
yeah we received a report of an
unidentified enhanced individual
operating out of this mosque pursuant to
us criminal code law enforcement
officers are not permitted to enter a
private space without a signed warrant
you study the criminal code in homeroom
an order reruns but i'm not wrong
no it's a very serious matter
it is in your best interest to cooperate
serious because your person of interest
is enhanced or because she was spot at a
mosque ma'am
next time
remove your shoes i wanna wear extra
shoes next time
it's wrong squishy that's what i call
john
damage control an armed government
agency came into the mosque today what
they stormed right in thinking that we
had something on her like we need
another target on our backs
and she doesn't even seem to notice him
she does know she doesn't care
wow that's a very real conversation yeah
completely ruined our election result
meeting
where
i
a board member
he became
a board member show excitement
why did you just say you won
maybe
dude
bro
oh
squishy
board board member
[Music]
oh
bruno came by earlier he said he
couldn't get out of his shift but he has
left this box for you
[Music]
it's my heart just a letter that says
comrade can suck it
just a drawing of cameron looking like
an idiot
[Music]
i appreciate that they're going down
this very like
real
way
totally
especially muslim girl in new jersey i
thought it would be cool to have a
superhero who actually fights for us i
don't know maybe she's just making
things worse
i doubt that boy from the minaret would
agree
so how does she convince everyone
that she's
good
good it's not a thing you are kamala
it is a thing you do
i know you're miss marvel
and i'm not going to tell anyone
but i will give you words of wisdom
along the way
inspired by batman
cool
yeah buddy
[Applause]
bruno with that nice paint job
it's just something for cultural studies
class
the gin
yeah
let me have a look look i'm actually i'm
good
please come on
you might learn something the jinn have
had many names across time and cultures
some call them genies others
demons legend tells of a group of hidden
chin clandestine and damned to live out
their days
trapped in our own
oh
they move in shadows oh no searching for
the key
that will help them get home
but to unlock such an ancient barrier
will require a primordial power mr khan
has a great voice
and these guys sound a lot more uh
we can't trust them
all these theoretical problems downplay
the margin of error and if you need the
energy of the sun think about how big
the margin of error must be
that's a great point try again this time
like you have a social life
maybe this is something i need to do
something
good
i got into caltech
oh
god damn
carol damer's went away
she'd punch a hole in space and time and
she'd help them now and carol danvers
would be reckless
maybe it's not such a bad thing that
you're not her
even the white men in the show don't
like
them from no one everyone's girlfriend
bad influence on you come on
have you ever felt like you're up
against the world
like you wanted something so bad and
then it actually happened but in reality
it's just not as great as you imagined
it
it's life kid
i found my family
and i let them love me whatever mountain
you're facing you don't have to do it
alone
[Music]
you know why the ahmed is getting
married
i should have a kid
make the kid love me make the kid love
me that's how you do it yeah
withhold love until the kid gives in
732
what's that
all the money i have in my checking
account
732
oh god you're about to get married a man
has one fundamental choice in life
to live a life
in fear
or love yes i agree with that love
chooses passion
he chooses
faith
courage
i agree i love this
you are brave my son
because you have chosen
family
and the man who chooses family
is never alone that's why i gotta have a
kid
make it love me
never alone new project
do you accept amir khan as your husband
i do
do you accept ahmed khan as your husband
i do do you accept the 739 dollars
[Laughter]
do you accept taisha hellman as your
wife
idea
you are now husband and wife i like that
he went more sincere the more i do's
[Music]
yeah it makes you really think of the
question
apparently it might be dangerous of
course it's dangerous why wouldn't it be
you knew
and you still asked kamala to do it
anyway this place will never be our home
we're going to make her help us
i'm not asking anymore
oh my gosh good i never suspected my mom
would be this aggressive
looks like the auntie got a hold of
bruno
yeah
that's why bruno comes to these things
oh my god
[Music]
yes
[Music]
get in there bud
everyone here is so much better than
kingo
you should show up right now
[Applause]
diwali and bar mitzvahs and sweet 16s
and quinceaneras yes
okay everyone let's slow it down no
don't ruin the wedding guys
don't ruin brown jovi oh come on knock
come run you're gonna you're gonna
interrupt this great moment you're not
safe none of you are safe
they'll kill everyone you have to get
out with me come on my whole family's
here right now i know i tried to call
you
oh [ __ ] oh ted's
intense oh my god
yeah
isn't that too easy
yeah sticks see the classics right
everyone just starts bollywood dancing
again
we can make a beat out of this
oh wow no oh holy crap he martial art of
the crap out of him
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god
jeez wow
ah
[Music]
damn i got nipple chills i know this is
such a punchy thing
got so used to the show i was like oh
yeah the action that's right superhero
[ __ ]
kamala pulled the alarm
so with my own eyes what are you talking
about you can't see anything you know
the dmv revoked her driver's license
they did as a fact
[Music]
how did you do that editing
i think the music like the original
music in this episode is
stellar
[Music]
oh my god red lighting you know it's
badass fighting
clever oh my god oh
no
cam run get in the fight learn to stand
up against your mother
oh my goodness
oh damn damn that belt dude
oh
how did you do that
please tell me
backhand
alone
oh
you got comrade
damn look at that sex appeal way to
stand up for brian
okay right now okay
where is
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you doing this you said you would
protect me what if her mom comes in
[Music]
holy moly
inception
whoa
way to go department of damage control
you are controlling the damage
[Music]
there's still damage but that's just
under control
[Music]
so you guys didn't see kamala matching
the identity of that superhero you were
looking for
i don't see a resemblance oh my gosh
i'm really sorry
oh no don't turn on her they're after
you
no no no no no no just knocking we'll
take care of me wait no just go
you drop this
i'm i'm gonna explain everything later i
swear
what just happened
okay are you okay no i'm not super
villain origins
[Laughter]
jesus you should have told me yeah i
will kill you now kept this from me
days
and hours
who were those people you were with they
were arrested
can you tell us what exactly happened
you might need to be honest man choose
family
just be honest with us give it a shot i
can't
teenagers crazy hormones
mtv
vaping
tick-tock
hi nani um hello kamala can i call you
later you need to come to karachi ah
great
did you see the train beta
oh how did you know about that because i
saw it too which is why you have to come
you have to come to karachi
oh damn
dang dude
that was great that was terrific it was
a great episode god man i kind of dialed
back some of those like um
you know
spock scott pilgrim inspired visuals
yeah but they they replaced it with
a lot of like mystery intention
yeah i thought yeah this one did nicely
to like really hone in on just the
cultural aspects at hand and then really
dialing up the intensity due to that
proximity to such you know
uh familial and warm ceremony and i
thought they had a really great balance
um
with going back and forth between you
know superheroes supernatural stuff
moving that forward and then
um the actual like just the families the
what the wedding the culture like you
said
life lessons you know i thought this was
a really great balanced episode of it
all yeah and i thought it culminated
uh quite natural too
and now we got an established villain
that's right
yeah
um them gin
i thought you were talking about nani oh
yeah nanaki is gonna use all the power
of the board to take kamala down i said
nani nani is the villain gotcha don't be
racist john sorry
they're all the same to me
[Laughter]
knock you
nakia the dad the mother i can't
they're just a bunch of the same
character
they're like the clones in star wars
all right
well no core here so we have nothing to
say you have nothing
no insights koi what did you think oh
that's right there's no koi
no
no this whole channel has been dependent
on him this whole time how are we going
to talk about this never ever will we
succeed who's in the show
what's the characters called
um
dr marvelous this muslim miss maisel
it's the miss maisel miss muslim maisel
yeah uh boy
yeah i thought this was an excellent
episode uh overall because
yes of everything we just briefly touch
on the credits of you know cutting
between like the cultures and the
superhero qualities like the beginning
part was uh you know other than like we
gotta get some
fun exposition out of the way you know
let's explain who the clandestines are
it had me fooled
i didn't expect something malevolent
peaking around the corner even though
i'm like i should have picked up on that
from the opening scene all the mom's
warnings
kind of the the presence of the second
episode of the reveal of her too like
yeah all the signs were indicating that
and it wasn't until the scene in the in
the
circle cue with bruno when i started
realizing oh wait yeah yeah
they might be actually like some bad
bad folk but what i liked about how they
executed them in in the at the wedding
scene was they did seem truly
threatening um they they seem like an
actual intimidating presence
and i thought they might have
you know pg'ed it up yeah children it
down a little bit make it more
kid-friendly and while it wasn't like
bloody or something of that nature that
it wasn't like brutal it still had an
impact and it still felt like these are
violent people and they will kill anyone
in their way they at least evoke that
emotion while watching this episode and
especially in that moment and i thought
like the action was like cool like
cooler than it has been
prior to that point
and it was actually intense and the
action served the plot it wasn't just we
needed an action scene so throw it in
here it actually propelled the plot
forward and was significant and it also
allowed for
characters to rise to certain occasions
and for them to develop a little bit
more with you know kamala rising to the
occasion of she keeps she keeps running
throughout that fight occasionally like
smacking people away but the whole point
she keeps running away but eventually
you know like when bruno is in danger
she steps up and just kicks some ass you
know showing that she's a superhero
she's protecting bruno stepping in
cameron stepping in some of that
development of cameron's a little weird
it's a little bit
yeah it was a little like
we're shifting fast with him
yeah
yeah it's one thing it's not the point
but but yeah i could maybe use a scene
or two if we are going to have that be
truly impactful i would like to see the
the struggle within him you know that
kind of leads him to i just feel like
yeah there's there's a whole side quest
off screen happening where he's like oh
what do i do my family but but kamala
um but yeah i think they've gotten a
really
they get really good mileage out of
quality filmmaking to me because like
you're talking about the action and
everything and yeah they do feel super
threatening and they mix i think really
well regardless of how people feel about
the change in the origin of her power i
think they mix really well the use of
just hand-to-hand combat or
slightly more upscale combat with you
know outlandish weapons and then using
the super
powered parts in between there and i
think that
allows for like a tempering where
there's like enough intensity that it
actually feels intense but there's
enough of that whimsy to bring it down
and you don't have to pg-13 it in such
an obvious way because you're not even
really thinking about the blood because
of how kinetic but also focused the
camera work is so you can really see
what's happening but it's also moving
fast enough that you get the impact of
everything well also because you're
showing these guys stepping in and just
flat out hurting it yeah it's hurting
people just wantonly hurting people yeah
we're like you don't need to hurt them
yeah like you don't need to punch that
guy what are you doing you don't have to
cause destruction here if all you want
to do is get home
yeah so there is that impact be because
of that because you see the the innocent
people who are in danger so evacuing
them from the wedding does seem
essential that comrade thing does need
didn't need some fleshing out though i i
really think so because it's just like
you hit me with my mother
oh yeah
you went behind my back and texted her
and there's just one scene where he's
like
mom
how could you mother i'm going to tell
her at once
i don't know why he's a dandy in my mind
i must save come on i must save kamala
she's in danger see
it uh it played a little
goofy in a way that didn't seem
flattering to the show if that makes
sense sometimes that uh little cheese
can be charming and to me it was oh okay
here we are yeah we have shifted gears
and um yeah i mean the the performer of
oh my god it's another name with an n
there's like three characters with n
names um
[Music]
kamran's mom yeah yes
it's either namja or najma i'm not sure
what a jj
yes uh
yeah i mean i i like the performance of
her a lot because she had me fooled when
she was sweet and then she said she's
scary when she's threatening yeah i
could have used
it's not a gripe but if i had to start
thinking of gripes i would say you know
i could have used maybe a little more of
just living in that place where you do
trust them because you know if we could
have maybe even reached the end of this
episode
and not really known until that fight
breaks out or something i think that
could have been cool because it was one
instance where i was like dang this
could go either way maybe they're just
misunderstood i'm becoming mark wahlberg
you know
like maybe these guys yeah like i can
see how they might be you know uh not as
benevolent as they appear but maybe it's
you know the mcu is getting better at
making
villains or or antagonists really who
are very understandable and who have
reasonable motivations but they just are
at odds with whatever the case is on
earth 616.
oh yeah uh i agree i agree with that um
but
at the same time i'm like no it was kind
of the dummy sitting here full no i was
too though it was like there's no
villains in the show no it got me part
way through because i was sitting there
and i literally had that thought of
i don't know way that's gonna they could
just you know end up being fine and i
don't know what's going to happen well
well i thought with the villainous
i thought the threat was not necessarily
you have i thought the threat they were
building up was the dodc yeah yeah
because i like what they're implementing
here was a path i
i didn't expect it to go down because
um
uh
six months ago i decided not to be
racist
so
my mind doesn't even ponder anymore oh
man of what you know possible prejudice
routes people can go i'll get there
someday
um yeah it wasn't a healthy place to
live john
six months ago when i said
i think i need to stop this it might get
me in trouble one day to give up my
racism habit and now that i've given up
my racism habit i'm a much healthier
person i think
it's that simple guys you look a lot
like choose not to segregate individuals
based off of race and appearance
don't discriminate based on things no
control over it's pretty easy to kind of
just decide not to do it don't be a dick
about facts of life you know um
as long as you just don't judge people
on the way they're born wow that simple
oh my god crazy um yeah well to go down
the path of uh
of like oh you got these government
people white folks kicking the goddamn
doors and going to mosques and [ __ ] see
now you're being racist again
white people that's all we do is just we
just kick down doors and be intolerant
justice for government agents right
you're right you're right i'm sorry i'm
sorry i didn't mean that okay i mean
that i'm here to stand up for for i'm
sorry my
all lives matter all of them especially
all the white ones that aren't getting
enough attention anymore
yeah being overshadowed uh the
where's koi his review is dangerously
woke right now we need coy to get us
back to comics who's not woke at all
no anti-wok
so yeah we we uh the the path they went
down
the thing always one joke about deciding
not to be racist
uh the the path they were they were
going down with you know the of like oh
my god this the there's a like a
terrorist slant
to it you know and because it's taking
place in new jersey which is like right
across the street from new york city
and
i respected them for going that and
going down that route because that is a
real struggle
that people in the muslim community have
had to really deal with
um especially since you know post 911 of
just being judged off of that appearance
alone so
them dealing
i liked what
the struggle was that kamala was having
uh and i would be curious to talk to
people who i know that are muslim and
who are you know indian or pakistani i
would like to be able to talk to them
because
um and then put them on camera and then
point to them and go that's my friend
see i'm not racist because six months
ago i decided i needed a friend for me
tracer i'm only going to show you off
when it relates directly to like to make
myself look better you know
type up the show
no
i don't know why this became the best
the most anti-woke woke review um
well uh
before we actually we were talking about
about how they bring up the concern of
how kamal is affecting the community
because it's not just you know looking
at the dodc and and seeing how they're
being really like chauvinistic and
you know kicking the goddamn door in and
just like
walking all over the place i i
appreciated getting the conversation
going between uh nakia
and
uh and also the the head of the mosque
of the current head of the mosque too
and and seeing different perspectives on
it while kamala's caught in the center
of
i wanted someone who represented us but
now my is by doing this actually
creating harm for the community and the
reputation when there's so much about
not getting involved in any forms of
something that cause like anything that
she does can be likened to violence yeah
when that's not the intention yeah
easily misinterpreted yeah it was like
criminal activity yeah and so you know
the purposes of the dodc getting
involved i think make it that much more
effective but i also appreciate the gray
that they pointed out here because the
dodc is often portrayed in the mcu and
and even into a certain extent in comics
because they're not they're not like
terrible people to deodc
they're like a lighter version of the
boy's attitude in a way
without having to wipe everything out
sort of like oh we gotta hardline these
things we gotta make sure that the order
is kept they really they're they're just
you know the the law enforcement that uh
kind of feels like it kind of gets in
the way and gets annoyed at soups and
[ __ ] but they
they
they at the end at the end of this
episode i thought it was neat that they
actually saved the day to be like guys
the odc does good things sometimes yeah
if they hadn't been here this might have
gotten more out of here and yeah because
i was watching it going how are they
gonna get out of the situation
yeah it's a good point and i mean i feel
like they've done really nicely in this
show especially to draw like
really well-proportioned
renditions of all these different
faculties of the story they have at
their disposal like the dodc it's like
okay that's where they are in their
development now is they can contain
certain advanced threats like this yeah
yeah and uh yeah it's i don't know like
they're so good in this show at doing
multiple things at once and and not
making it seem like it or not garishly
pointing to things to make sure that you
know about whatever fan service thing
like they're really good at yet putting
a human story
on top of a growing you know universe of
implications about heroes and powers and
now they're also filtering that through
you know we've not to again go too woke
but like we have a lot of white heroes
who just get to have their hero journey
and don't really have to think about
like well what am i doing for my actual
community of people who still has a hard
time you know being accepted into the
greater culture of where we all you know
like it's great at doing those things
and feeling so natural about it without
ever like pointing and going yeah see
see see
and so yeah it's like you
i'm curious to see how that ultimately
meld all that into what the clandestines
are doing right and if they have an
ultimate point because like i love the
ground level stuff and and seeing her
family and seeing their concerns and
seeing like even the stuff between
aranaki i thought was really well
tempered too about how she still doesn't
know
and kamal is a little distracted but not
in a way that's too obvious
and uh yeah like all that stuff has so
much like rich lifey you know it's
relevant but again in not a garish way
and i want to see how that affects the
ultimate outcome of both where the dodc
ends up as a force of
vague like they're antagonistic at times
given their whole raisin detra and then
you have you know the clandestines who i
wonder how kind of understandable and
what kind of metaphor they could stand
in for by the end of this because
it was i guess when it comes to their
turn some of that stuff is about the
only thing in this episode that feels a
little quick and so i hope they can
join some of the other
quality mcu villain
antagonist you know
characters in that gallery of ones who
have really understandable motivations
and and you know are well drawn
characters
as well because i think that would just
tie this whole thing together with a bow
you know yeah i would i hope the writing
does uh get better on them at the same
time it's i also don't think the show is
particularly interested in
you know being all like she's gonna be
in like the marvels and so that's when
that's when they'll get all like crazy
um
but they're they're laying like i really
think that was cree related the bangle
at the beginning
yeah and and then you know with being in
the marvels and [ __ ] um
there's gonna be some it's gonna be cool
but
i also don't want the show to go that
big yeah no it's totally when this
kicked off with like inter-dimensional
[ __ ] i'm like i i just like no what's
been what's been working about this is
how
really grounded this is and
how there's just so much life and
conversation and relationships that by
the time you got to the wedding i was
like oh damn a lot of the
the action moments while not the
craziest action in any of these marvel
shows the the action is really feeling
intense because we've just spent so much
time
dealing getting to know these characters
and the relationships and the dynamics
of it all that you do feel the tension
from them so i'm like that makes the
action so much more rewarding because
they haven't been in a rush to get to
action whatsoever out of almost three
hours of television well so much of this
episode is about
coping with the action from the end of
the last episode which was not much yeah
yeah yeah but they make a lot out of the
emotional response to it which i think
is really clever yeah and i think oh my
god i'm blanking on her name uh what's
kamala khan's actor's name do you know
what the mind iman fellaini valani
iman
iman villani momvalani i'm putting my
chips on on that um
i thought what she did here
again um she's she's just so superb as
an actor uh it's brilliant
i say actor because about four months
ago i decided not to be sexist oh good
and i i think
i think every couple months man i i
believe um
uh every and all women prefer to not be
distinguished to an actor and actress
sure i think it's kind of a hive mind
thought they have act personally i
learned this on my path to not being
sexist
they have a hive mind
um they do
that's how their periods get synced
[Music]
so they can control when they do it
uh-huh oh they caused me so much stress
john yep
yes that's the whole fun of it man if
you could do that you would too um
anyway her anti-sexism
her performance
here um
and we were talking about adult actors
actresses too uh we i want to just
really clarify the conversation that we
were not talking about teen actors at
that moment when john brought up that
biological situation anyway
um why'd you make things awkward john
um that's what i'm here for we are so
far down that hole now we're peeking out
the other side um the the
her performance here
i feel like the route that a lot of
people would tend to go is kind of a
more
expressive anxiety situation
where they might be a little bit more
frantic in their behavior what i really
liked was how
you know she was so lost in thought most
of the time and it was kind of weighing
her down internally a little dazed
yeah i thought that was i don't know if
that was like her choice or if that was
just the director's choice or in the
writing either way it's a good choice
and well played you know like when when
um
nakia tells her like i'm on the board
and it takes her a moment to realize it
and how she responds i thought felt so
real the way
she wasn't like
what what wow like like you know she
like the transition into saying those
following lines was so real
and even dealing with like bruno um can
be uh revealing that he went to he's
going that he got accepted into caltech
and how she handles her reactions there
and just watching out weighs down on her
just felt
like this this feels more real than
someone who's like
overacting the panic yeah you know and
and i i really just she is so good she
is so
so so good um
and i i really hope that people
recognize that because she brings so
much layers oh yeah and
if if there's
like she hasn't been coined and i really
like the build up to what do we call her
like it's called miss marvel but i
really like the build up of
you know establishing what noon is and
and and um you know
no what
what about manure manure
i hate
manure
um
the time traveler time traveler's wife
dude best know my movies
[Music]
you know you just extend a little bit
there you go
um
newer
when i first when i first learned the
word
i realized
i'm not playing miss marvel
um
inside impression
[Laughter]
it's topical let's talk we got this we
got this guys we're so close we're just
in a rush before koi's about to cut us
off yeah
yeah before we hold our breath and chloe
just goes we're just like i know cory
wants to say a lot
oh my dude sorry koi your reasoning for
not being here cracks me up so it's just
a roast session for you we are gonna
have a black phone off screen just to
summon this is going to be the koi phone
i didn't give him the pass that would be
like yeah we can't come it's it's
totally cool um but i i thought it would
be because this is your fault i thought
it would be because he was off of a
flight yeah i know not because i charged
up and i went out to an event
which i get it you know you got ties i
understand but at the same time i'm like
it sounds like you had a full party yeah
and then a half hour before supposed to
show up
can't do it gonna get to this party man
a few drinks in oh no i forgot what
parties are and how they work
fundamentally it's so funny so funny
anyway it brings a smile to my face um
oh i imagine coy hung over in bed right
jackass coy you jackass just call him in
the morning and pretend there's a new
thor trailer
just have him show up here and then just
you decide
it's going to drop in an hour i got
early access
could you drive over
oh so sorry dude the file got corrupted
just before you got here i'm sorry man
and apparently they're not going to
upload it
apparently they're scrapping this little
trailer because the movie comes out in a
week
or two weeks whatever uh but yeah this
is a really good episode everyone did an
excellent job and and yeah sure uh you
guys leave your theories down below
and all that crap dad is great
everyone's great hulk shirt came back
it was a lot of information at the
beginning though
it was i'm excited to go um to karachi
because i'm hoping for more like it was
really cool to be and especially on the
heels of moon night i was like oh well
timed because you're in sort of a
mystical but also you know culturally
very distinct place and i i hope for
more of that in a more breathable way
yeah instead of like whoa
i wonder if they actually film it in
karachi
that would be cool and i wouldn't uh it
seems like something they could do for a
project like this
you know with all these
actual
people
in the show that would be
pretty cool it'd probably be a movie
like got ethan hawk to go over there
a bunch of these actors over
what's oscar isaac again he's like he's
like ecuadorian and something or i don't
know well got him over to egypt jewish
though united's jewish that's fair oscar
isaac's probably he's got some jewish
well i appreciate that they really
embrace um the pakistani culture though
i think that's all right that's a really
admirable admirable decision too because
it really does feel like you're watching
like one of those teen coming of age
movies about another call like in a way
there's a little bend it like beckham
almost in here for me not that's the
best touchstone but you know something
where it's like oh yeah it's just about
kind of coming of age and and
fitting in in a place that doesn't
actively welcome you yeah like super bad
like super bad dude this is like super
bad i like seth and evan or drill bill
taylor taylor yeah so i get all the
right references totally totally project
x project x yeah
thousand percent man ten things i hate
about you totally dude it's all in here
uh mike and dave need wedding dates
ingrid goes west
yeah i guess that that that's accurate
anyway
all right guys well let us know all your
crazy
theories actually the last thing we
talked about is mcu connections whatever
well i mean this show doesn't seem too
interesting
which hey i mean not to slight fun mcu
tie-ins but i will take this show that's
like super invested in its characters
and in telling like a really fluid
stylistic story
i will take that absolutely a hundred
times over
yeah cause honestly i kind of i slightly
missed it the first time i heard it um
about the interdimensional beans like oh
that's right they're interesting
they just kind of sound like humans that
have been here forever yeah yeah no
there's going to be if they're going to
do some mumbo jumbo where there's the
interdimensional magic and jinns but
then there's also cree something we can
kind of inch toward pterogenesis even
well i want them to do a little bit more
of you know like see what the mcu's
versions of gins are like because so
much of the time gins and
you know other mediums are like spooky
cheetahs
yeah man
this is some scary supernaturals
yeah
yeah totally
no no i'm rooting for them to yeah like
if they do go more supernatural i want
to see it based on you know it's like
they were reading off the the you know
uh urdu on the you know information that
bruno had in that great scene with the
dad and and like stuff like that i'm
like yeah if you're gonna dive into
you know big over-the-top and and
mystical and effects and
inter-dimensional do it through that
lens and and i think that'll be true
enriching
all right well
here we are we're we're at the end my
friend
this is the end that's the october list
all right cool
all right
we're getting ready to shout out people
who pledged last year yeah yeah because
they're
anyway guys thanks for being here catch
us next week
now that obi wan is not
over people really watch this marvel
show yeah maybe the numbers will pick up
yeah
100k views
is peasant views
hey i just want this to do well on
disney plus that's it i keep all i keep
seeing the angry mob of people be like
it's failing
because people hate women and anybody
who's not white
i don't know i never know how to how to
read how these shows are doing anymore
because those those headlines go out and
i'm like is it is there's no one
watching this
maybe because a lot of people
are watching it'll be exciting
they're watching the star wars event
yeah where darth vader's back yeah
um anyway
i mean just compete with obi-wan and
still get like almost 800 000 viewers
it's [ __ ] impressive that is
absolutely i'm happy to hear that it's
still impressive so even like know the
context people yeah
[ __ ] racist
just patron of the day shout out
rosa you
you kind of remind me of like a really
cool version of the mom in this show
because even though the mom is
protective even though she's always
looking out for kamala and even though
when kamala's like i can't tell you
stuff she's got that disappointment face
you know that her character is of the
utmost sterling gold standard and that's
you rosa you
you are so sophisticated
you have such wonderful taste you are a
giver and a carer and a nurturer and a
critical thinker amen and i am
frequently inspired i'm always so happy
when i see your posts pop up see you
active
out there in the ether
talking and dissecting and breaking
things down it's an inspiration and
that's the real me you don't need a
bangle for that magic okay that's all
you rosa so
she doesn't need a bangle
you're a bang bangladesh bangalore main
thing you're a bait you're a bagel
you're a bagel
sucked into a bagel
ah yes time traveler's way yeah
dudes best movie it has inspired a lot
of others
let me tell you rosa get on that review
time travel definitely seen that movie
what do you think of it
[Music]
you